just ask you to remain standing for the
opening prayer please
father we just come before you and thank
you uh for the privilege that you have
bestowed upon us to to
to work out or work our way through this
agenda today
and to make decisions uh within the best
interests of our of our community
which is thank you and ask in jesus name
bless this place
amen
and now i think
things are reasonably straightforward
the exception of the mirrors um mike who
doesn't work which doesn't work
i think if you want to talk if you
wouldn't mind just pushing your
button uh and leaving non-white
iteal tool turning it off
the when you put push the button it
should turn
a solid wreath
um
um to begin with apologies we have an
apology
uh this afternoon from councillor grant
doug grant
uh and also from council davis someone
would like to move those apologies be
sustained as
uh counselor bulger thank you and
segment of that councillor
declaration of council conflicts of
interest are there
any items on the agenda today where
councillors might have a conflict that's
not part of their
declared conflict of interest
tonight so if there is something arises
and i'm sure you'll
make us known that uh confirmation
of minutes and reports and we have a
confirmation of the minutes of the
ordinary meeting of council
held on tuesday 8th december
some would like to move that be seen as
a true and correct record of that
meeting
council heisted second to council bulger
thank you
is there any alteration to that record
required
it's not i'll put that motion all those
involved please
against emotions i have to say i'm
pretty impressed with the acoustics in
here
i don't know whether other people are
finding it good but i find this
really easy compared to what we have
been in the past
um we'll move on then to item four which
is fish and lake business
uh is there any urgent late business to
table this afternoon
there's not thank you counselors
and we have the appointment of the
deputy
electoral officer and we have a
under the electoral act 2001 we do have
to appoint
both a literal officer and a deputy
electoral officer
of course the council made a conscious
decision um
a few years ago to appoint elections.com
as its preferred election provider and
that
company stands in the shoes as a
electoral officer
but we still have to have a deputy who
is
on the ground and can actually feel
that the day-to-day inquiries that will
come in from
people particularly in the run-up to an
election
uh the previous chief financial officer
lou blackbeard
fulfilled that role well
but in preparation for the next uh
election cycle
we need to appoint a replacement and i'm
very happy that uh our new general
manager
and regulatory community rebecca taylor
has put a hand up and is prepared to
fill that role as deputy electoral
officer subject to the council's
approval
thank you steve okay so it's open
for discussion and your recommendation
and
recommendation is a three-part
recommendation
but certainly from my perspective it
makes sense that
mrs taylor would be
thank you um i'm happy to move the
recommendation
all right
thank you is there any discussion on
that
it's not i'll put the motion all those
in favor please say all right
okay item three a an update from the
chief executive
on the three waters reform which is
moving at pace as we speak and
pretty substantial in its um
it's our pain to review and reform
waters for the whole
it's really becoming quite clear that
the government is very serious about
reform in this area
and i guess every time there is
um an instant involving
water supply or waste water
um rupturing and linking to waterways
that only probably um provides
fuel and cements the resolve of powers
of b
that change is required so uh it's a
matter really
of trying to the best we can
get in front of that change and uh make
sure that
our concerns are heard and um
find their way into the design of any
new
regime that may be entered into
there's an enormous amount of detail and
questions that still need to be
uh teased out um and i
keep saying i was still sad that i
believe the timetable
government has is incredibly ambitious
um and one does wonder
uh how much uh is known
in the community in general up and down
new zealand
about the reforms and what they
may entail but as a sediment report
there is an important meeting in monaco
on the 17th of march
which is worship line will be attending
certain carriages
encourage councillors to attend because
all councils in south island will be
present
i'm sure that will spawn a lot of
interesting debate and discussion around
what the future holds and how
communities may operate under this new
proposal which is probably the biggest
of its type in
30 odd years
thank you god just
reiterate that councillors are able to
make it to monaco on sydney
to make the idea
um my child of local government is only
being one other reform that has been on
scale this one is and that's when
amalgamation happened
so it's going to have a significant
effect not just on us but
on every local authority their form and
function going forward i believe
so being informed is pretty critical
um i know
um i've had the pleasure of being at the
waitangi celebrations
uh at the weekend uh
and the lectures for those who've
not been to the waiting celebrations a
formal part of
the proceedings are in the morning and
then the afternoon there's a series of
lectures on various subjects
pretty much all of those lectures in one
way or another
um focused on water this year and
were fascinating and of course
my
so that's going to be an interesting
factor in this whole process
going forward as well so
i'll open that full discussion
city councils want to make any comments
on this particular item
or would you like to just recommend that
we
note the decision and take note of the
cabinet paper that's attached
i just wanted to make a comment that if
we
opt out of council's opt-out they must
be aware of
stronger enforcement and more costs
which i think is
concerning i'd be surprised
to see any of
my yeah of
my interpretation of
the uh report i got the impression that
the reforms or the the scale of the work
ahead is so great and accepted
as being so of such magnitude that
it's beyond the ability of the local
government allowing to fund so
i was somewhat heartened by that no
you know i might have been reading
something into it or certainly looking
for it
there would be some uh probably some
central government um
support to carry out the work over the
time frame that they appear to be
heaven and head and mind obviously
change
the way we treat water and assessment
just in recent days with the
challenge around weka white on two other
smaller communities our targets
on anything that potentially can go
wrong okay there's nothing to further
would somebody like to move the
recommendation
thank you councilors thank you
all those of you please stay on thanks
motion
uh i've seen another substantial
issue that council does need to grapple
with but
to make substantial progress and
advancement in this particular area
there's
also a need for some
serious buy-in from central government
but have a report
[Music]
um
didn't get dropped
[Music]
is
uh
okay thank you for opening for
discussions
back in the spring of last year so that
we could see
the what the trends were in relation to
the decision that the council took
um pre the commencement of the financial
year in terms of
um withdrawing from all forms of
recycling apart from
the glass being collected and
obviously it has uh generated
more waste in the community with the the
offerings we currently have
and apart from alerting you to
the trend which is um not
welcome in terms of the financial trend
and the increase
in waste that coupled with the
government's clear intentions to
increase the waste levy
it does prompt the question as to
whether
the current settings that the council
has in respect
of waste collection services
is appropriately uh positioned and
whether there needs to be some further
um thinking around where
we need to make some amendments to to
actually
encourage or incentivize reduction of
waste because at the moment
if waste goes up in volumes
it leads to higher charges and
ultimately rate payers
will have to fund it so that's probably
probably your worship
a secondary consideration beyond this
report
but the council may find it useful if it
wanted for example to form a small
working party to work through some
options and report back to the council
and readiness for any changes you may
want to introduce before the
commencement of the next financial year
thank you um so the report is
open for discussion um
already today and i've got no doubt that
it will be
subject to coverage into the future um
certainly here's some comment on
up and down the country are really
struggling to grapple
with this particular situation that we
find herself in
and we're no exception to that
i think probably the suggestion that
you've accepted it's made about
a small working party it's not a bad one
to
to go forward but
one thing is for sure uh waste
the cost of waste and the style of
disposal
is going to be a source of community
interests for a long time to come
and we need to be making sure that we're
making every road
a winning right in terms of dealing with
the challenge that we have
personally i believe that the
remedy to waste oil as much as it can be
a remedy the reduction in waste
starts at a very young age and i think
that
we need to be doing what we can
to get into schools and talk to children
about
just what the challenges are and where
the opportunities are
so i believe that in time
that will help us a long way we can't
continue to ramp up the body of the
waste that we're dealing with now
and just do what we are doing
anyway open for discussion
i hope people realise that councils
caught between a rock and a hard place
the options are recycled recycled
in a sensible and economic manner that
was removed from us
two reasons the markets overseas don't
exist any longer
and the the options are recycled
recently um
was going to prove to be that expensive
that the losses that we that we're
making or the
increased costs that we're now making
would have been probably double
so i hope people realize that that
council has trimmed its budget or made
decisions to try and reduce
these costs it's ironic to me
that central government is not coming up
with a recycling solution
but at the same time increasing
per ton rate taxes at the landfill
you know i i think it is somewhat
irresponsible uh yes the solution cycle
don't generate waste and will cost you
nothing but
you know extremely extremely difficult
to do and and you know i have to admire
your confidence mr hoax
and i wait
but certainly doing what we were doing
uh was not going to
remedy the situation and a number of
councillors
councils uh including some closer to us
are continuing to separate waste but
it's going nowhere
my understanding is that it's being
stored
so i think yeah it's
committed to this council facing up to
the situation that we just can't keep
um recycling or potentially it was
stainless recycling
and storing it all over the place and
having to deal with it again
sometime in the future where there's no
concrete plans about what the future
might look like
thank you worship um it was a really
good report peter thank you for that
it's quite comprehensive
um and a couple of things i did pick out
of it were
the fact that um
there are a reusab recycling depot at
the site at the tip site maybe for
um recycling i don't know i can see
bikes and things like that there so
i think that's a good way to go too it's
interesting what some people can recycle
i know a lot of our ratepayers are very
happy about the
green waste free not being used anymore
and i just wonder too would it be a
solution to have perhaps
the yellow then go down to a two months
left collection
because a lot of people say i've got
nothing to go in it
um so just in a personal level i don't
contribute much either
but um and i also know that sonja our
communications officer is going to do
some work around
public education about minimising waste
usage so i look forward to that i think
that's a good way to go as well
so that's all i have to say thank you
i don't think it's going to work but um
three questions is probably first of all
the transport
costs going from 20 to 30 now that we've
got the compactor
online should be probably in line down
to the 20
to big competitive rate and i'm just
wondering if anything has been done with
that that's my first question
second question is probably going
through to the um
the um a shortfall as 288 000 now
is where is that going to be funded is
that going to be funded
on the rubbish bins charge or is it
going to be put across
on a capital basis or where is it going
to go and the third question
would be um you're just
probably wondering oh no
that's probably the main two it's those
two questions first of all
the transport charge now that we've got
a compactor on board the budget figures
should be lower and we
should be able to renegotiate transport
costs lower
uh to be competitive and also where that
shortfall is coming from
okay um
i think what we have agreed with the
revised special contract rate for us
after compactor installation the corner
turning per turn rate will be 22
percent not 20. it has been already
agreed
in the contract to stay
it's a question the second question
uh the deficit your council's funding
policy will
dictate that so solid waste has its own
discrete funding policy where the
majority of
the um i would think that probably
all of those costs would be absorbed by
the
waste um you know i think i've told my
head here that probably
um it would be as per the funding policy
where
about 90 percent or 87 percent off top
ahead
is funded by those that receive the
service and there's a residual
small percentage uh in the uagc
uh in terms of recognises that all
district residents have access to the
transfer station
but the the main chunk of it will be
those that receive
the kerbside recycling service because
they fund
the third question i forgot was um the
loan for the competitor
um um peter was saying it's for five
years not 15 years is that right or
just the figures there stack up for a 15
year loan
in the numbers initially
we proposed to the council with the
finance
financial assistance that we should be
considering
[Music]
only in the recommendation i think that
figures have been not picked up
correctly that's what people mean
instead of 288 it says 277
yeah just just the twenty seven thousand
two hundred and eighty six dollars
doesn't
um wipe out the line in five years right
money it doesn't even doesn't have to
show
yes i just i agree with uh councillor
garland that if you've got a three
hundred and seven thousand dollar loan
over five years you'll need to be
putting aside more than twenty seven
thousand that's
that's countless point
so i think that's the point of um mr
stand ring is that that particular
figure is incorrect because it's now
been set across five years is that
correct
peter yeah so i think
just for everybody's clarity um
we need to have those figures updated um
and those tables updated so that we can
just see exactly what we have agreed to
uh and what the proposal is so
if i take it it's read that what you're
saying is correct but i think it's
pretty important for the record
that we get that one
i'd just like to say that i think
council has a responsibility to
incentivize people
to actually reduce their waste because i
i think it's unfortunate that
the waste has risen and i know it's
because we're not recycling
but could we as a province look at how
we could utilize um plastic
and likes a glass bottle so i don't see
a point of
crushing them it's even off to the tower
we could be um using glass bottles again
and look at different ways of using
their
plastics that can be recycled
so i i know that um wasting
constantly looking at these challenges
on our behalf and on behalf of
other two local authorities but a
representative of my standards
do you want to make any comment
yes part of the issue here is
contrary to popular belief um recycling
was
was not the financial gold mine that
possibly it was um
promoted as and so really what it came
down to it was a recovery of costs
yes i know i'm stressing it you worship
really come down the recovery of costs
which became very very difficult as
as markets drive up the other issue we
have will be labor against and
as a region and we don't get the volumes
to have a regional solution and so we
find ourselves in a position where we
we would like to send it somewhere
inside new zealand
my own personal opinion it's a personal
opinion not a council opinion
it's definitely not a waste yet opinion
i've heard the question posed why do we
not burn plastic and generate heat and
generate electricity
um i haven't had anybody come back and
say
why that was a terrible idea i wonder if
that's
something that central government might
consider along with a whole a lot of
other options
it was just that we had a paper mill
sitting here at the tower and a british
plant and
just wondering if there's any
possibility of utilizing those so
that type of disposal that um is
talking about council vulture but i also
think we can't afford not to recycle
i know it's costly but we just can't
keep on doing what we're doing because
it's not
sustainable putting it rubbish in the
ground
and understand exactly what councilman's
saying as well
simply doing what we've done in the past
is not going to cut it and we need to
look for other alternatives
i'm aware that there are other countries
that are you know pretty sophisticated
countries that have
high temperature incineration uh that
generates
heat as well so i think all of those
things are
up for consideration um you talk about
the play of the old platform building i
know
future once the waste is gone and
in terms of the old briquette one there
have been
at least two
interested parties there
no doubt that this is going to keep
costing us a lot of money
okay any other questions
just a view on
the point that you've seen have raised
around a wastewater pattern
i think that's probably a good way to go
but i'm looking to get councillors
feedback on that
we need to be actively considering all
those options on a regular basis so i
think
any commentary
i don't think my life's gonna work it
just in regard to the
uh working party and um listen to the
commentary
around the increase obviously if we keep
going six percent a year
um i noticed that the emotions actually
returned to their a
long-term plan and the funding issues
that
are attached that we clearly obviously
need some some reasonably
um sensible and logical input
from the local people that have been
involved in
either recycling or hypnotist how
rubbish has been dealt with
prior to this to
assist with um moving forward
but i'd be keen to look at um outcomes
because i know there's various groups of
work in the community trying to
um deal with some of the recyclables um
yeah the other issue is uh with our
question
just around the six percent increase uh
and
i think it may be in here is that with a
change in our
collection obviously there's
that's obviously what's happening um is
that
correct that because the
move and how we provide the business
service
and it's giving an opportunity for
people to put more rubbish into the
system but
it still doesn't establish this rubbish
starting from somewhere
and obviously must exist prior to us
enabling them to be um
[Music]
so there's a chicken before here like do
we actually need to go right back
to square one and say uh where is this
rubbish
actually starting from and we actually
hit it at that point
not trying to have the ambulance
which we seem to be looking looking in
the uh
revision there at the moment having me
understand that we have the expertise to
work that out how we
look at packaging type packaging
available
uh centering rubbish system and is there
any
packaging does that pass the consumers
that way through
is
you know i was just going to thank you i
was just going to support the working
party
written all over my notes because
there's been a significant shift in the
information we've received
to the update but i do pick up on rich's
point and there's an opportunity to have
some external
uh stakeholders on that working parties
such as pakistan
that would be very useful i mean
is
um
um
um
just we should just clarify um i think
it's appropriate that
some of those parties you might be
mentioned would could be included in the
work and how the others may well
be invited to come and have an audience
with the working party
because there may be issues around
conflict of interest and to just to help
the word and pray to understand
what the the forces are out there that
are driving up the current situation
okay so we're adding that to the list of
recommendations
and also added to that an update
yeah just a point for me on that
recommendation you're ashamed that
the shelf will be funded from an
appropriate prison for consideration
in the 2021 uh long 20 25 30 one month
don't blame
i think consideration needs to be in
there because of some challenges in that
planning round i believe
as all councils do
right with those uh additions and
alterations
would somebody like to move those
recommendations
[Music]
last
things
um
tomorrow
[Music]
requirements for
not totally
[Music]
it's open for discussion i know that
this council has had quite a lot of
connection with this over the last
month or so and we're all very aware
that
it's emanated out of some funding that
was made available
from nzta to make and to improve
the ability of people to be active and
things other than vehicles not
discounting vehicles but
making our town a more friendly place in
terms of
recycling
so there has been quite a bit of
connection with various
cities and parts of the community
working groups
there's been quite a bit of publicity
generated
around this and the last few days i
understand there's been
quite a bit go out as well and
maybe sonja then you can perhaps give us
give us a bit of an update on
where that's at so um we've got quite a
plan going
around the communications and um
participants we've had um obviously
council
councillors and just
roll out the initiatives to the
community through that event they also
do a general experience
so we've got stuff happening going
forward and we'll continue that through
the
trials and a really
just to test what's um what's possible
uh what's acceptable
uh and what proves to be successful and
so
it doesn't doesn't go forward um
and i'm talking about properties or
houses that have
have trials in front of them for example
if the street's going to be
caused by one way and in front of your
house you can have an area blocked off
which
could potentially contain some form of
entertainment or equipment i think i'd
like to have it knock on my door
so i'm happy with the recommendation
provided we include in that that
we'll directly engage with property
owners
that are directly affected with changes
in front of their
their buildings or their houses so
including
business owners and house owners and
maybe the one each side just just in
terms of i think that will go a long way
in terms of buy-in if we
make that easter effort so i think the
staff are quite
attuned to doing that
[Music]
and talking to people
public with assurance various workshops
and
matters regarding emergency services we
do have that
that is basis in regard to the strengths
that we're
proposing or excess ways to imposing
very
so
[Music]
can
from the group and the workshops and
also from members of the business and
the residential community
it's been a great event so yeah we're
about to get a response
just hope that everyone out there gets
behind it
thank you i just got one question um
the legality if if there was an accident
on a bit on these
new
these crossings is a governance group
who is actually physically liable
us that put it there by a recommendation
or is it the driver or the person that
crossed the crossing
we call these
quite clearly
and
is
so as far as liability
uh my view would be that
if someone has an accident on roadworks
and
road works are undertaken up and down
the country
often they are offering severely
compromised
travelling conditions for motorists over
a short period of
short route um and so motorists need to
be alive to
any new features on the road
and take preventative measures
accordingly so i don't see the council
suddenly being held liable if someone
doesn't
take sufficient precautions and
coupled with publicity that we have in
mind
it's not as if that we're going to the
dead of night introduce a whole array of
surprise features
that are designed to trap people and
have
an array of accidents occurring so
so the good the good care uh good
communication
uh and the fact that uh
um roadworks happened up and down
throughout new zealand
along with what i say trials and in the
past with trial
roundabouts and what have you and put in
place
pretend obstacles to actually um
imitate a proposed run out for the
roundabout for example
they are all um managed and so i don't
envisage that the council but
be held liable and secondly
there there needs to be an upswing in
excellence
well i understand the comment and the
question that's been raised
and it's something that's gone through
my mind from time to time
i take heart from from what i've heard
um
in the various times it's been canvassed
around this table and
other forums and also that
the the promoter and the funder of this
is the nation's largest
road controlling authority and and also
representing the government so
i don't think anybody's entering into
this frivolous manner
and the comments the chief executives
made i think are
appropriate in terms of liking to
a road work situation
and any of us that get behind the wheel
of a car
uh or walk across a road uh have got
certain responsibilities to
fill it up too and to take on board and
and sometimes accidents happen and
sometimes people make silly mistakes
um but we are all human so a guy
i'm not sure whether that answers your
question counselor phillips or not
um but certainly i feel comfortable with
because in a road work situation you're
governed by
legislation under a dmp which is a
traffic management
this is not a traffic management
scenario this is a trial
where we're going to put in concrete
barriers
in the middle of the road that would not
non-existent even though in their trial
a trial i'll be extremely interested to
see how
the gore drivers perform with these
trials because i
like other people driving law and
they're not very good drivers some of
them
i'm i'm a heart to know that there's
going to be a lot of education for the
young children because they need to be
educated on how
to use these because i can see
certain seriousness coming on if if
they're not educated
and that includes the drivers of thor
once again i'll just say that
it's going to be interesting to see when
they shut the roads off how much comment
comes back
i take them towards the concerns of rose
council flips
and and i have no doubt that
when this is actually activated and
people
are aware and have to change some of the
habits that they've had for a lifetime
including myself and i find that that
hard to do on
on numerous occasions lately
that there will be a lot of comment and
that's really what this is about
it's about getting that comment um and
considering whether it's
a valid comment uh considering whether
there are
slight alternatives or complete changes
or removal required
um and i guess that's really why we're
in this situation now and if we don't
uh convince the trial then we will never
know
but certainly the landscape and the
townscape
has changed dramatically over the years
since the time that our school is laid
out when horse cart was
the main means of transport
uh to to what we currently um have now
in terms of you know electric scooters
and electric bikes
and uh and electric cars
um so i think that we need to be fit for
purpose
and this is just an attempt to get
our community fit forward not just today
but also for the future will what's
rolled out
be perfect in every respect i doubt it
i'd be most surprised uh will uh what's
confirmed at the end of the trial
the uh what is wrong there will it start
i'll
i'd lay money that it won't be um but
there will be some good things coming
through from this and
i think will take us as a community on
my journey into the future
okay um is there any further comments
i'm happy to move the recommendation but
i would like to start it in that
that we know there'll be face-to-face
engagement with property owners directly
by features outside their property
i think that's a good idea and you're
moving you're signing that counselor
thank you so with that addition um
the motion is put to any further comment
there's not i put the emotion always in
favor
against the motion of this carrier and
just before we
carry on i want to say thank you to all
of those
both staff and and those from the
community have been involved
in this process from day one it hasn't
been
easy getting to the start point let
alone getting to the end point
um but i certainly
approach you for what you've done today
thank you
right we'll move on into um
[Music]
that we need to know about with regard
to the community material
[Music]
uh inquiries from the community uh since
the tournament exposes to what is
happening before building
as it stands the the building is a
liability community
[Music]
a number of employees have come from
different groups within the community as
to
being able to use it from health and
fitness clubs to
men shared in different organizations
one of the biggest challenges i think
that the
was to provide facilities for uh all
ages
and that was one of the um the prime
movers if you like
of when the pool is closed the pool can
be used
by all groups and and interestingly
enough
it was the older generation that were
more against the poor closing than
probably some of the younger ones
so that was a challenge for the
community uh for the community board
and in your consultation with the
community
um and i have to say that and um
can say to the council that the the
black part that was built in place
has been a huge success and
uh we see that the poor building could
be used in conjunction with that you
don't see many people
riding on a little white car with the
same color as here as i heard
but there is many parents and and
grandparents that are there with
families
that um with for picnics or birthday
parties
and we we could see that this could be
used in conjunction with the phyllis
facilities that have been built there
for indoor activities and especially for
going back to some of our age
community um we have received a couple
of
um
we call those estimates
estimates as to the cost uh of of
of building a new floor which holds
apart and so
our i suppose coming to council we would
like to investigate
the feasibility of being able to make
this
building uh usable for the community in
the wider community
and um you know so that's that's that's
i guess we're coming back
just to investigate those possibilities
thanks everyone
[Music]
working party council represented the
council grant and some of the members of
the community board to look at the
redevelopment
and i guess when i read not being in the
meeting but reading my recommendations
here i'm a little bit confused
as to what the strategy is and i i don't
think the council should be going and
getting costings until
we've actually got a vision and a agreed
strategy so
i'm feeling we might be the stage
meeting of a joint working party with
the community board to talk about
where this is going we haven't fulfilled
the talent park redevelopment running on
stage one
we're now got stage two as a possibility
and and incorporating the building
i i'm just not clear on where we're
going and
the group sentiment's the journey board
but there's a strong influence here
saying council needs to stump up and and
uh not not leave that community board to
do it and i guess i'm not up to speed
with that so
i'd like to understand where we're going
here
what it's going to cost and who's going
to pay
i think probably
i guess before that it would be good for
the council to meet with the community
and discuss
what the vision is here
because we closed the pool closed the
building
wasn't part of the redevelopment
proposal
so just to be clear
[Music]
thank you i'm just answering a couple of
great's questions
the pool itself was actually going to be
utilized as part of the first
development
with the pump track and the pump trip
was going to go through the building
um it failed in that aspect is that it
cause of security reasons
and here's what was left my question at
the board board meeting was why was the
building
and why has the building been left to be
a derelict building
and i emphasized the word derrick
because it's been nothing done to the
building
maintenance-wise for over five years
it's a council-owned building i don't
want to see
it looking like another james hemingway
and
i question why
and breakfast said it once again who was
going to pay
now the question to me is why should
that question be put to the community
board
every time it wants to do something
hello why
the last few years but i think the
derelict is probably not the right term
my clear understanding was that when the
council put forward half a million
dollars
that that would be the leverage
and i think that's really where they
step
there needs to be a vision
goals
i guess there'll be lots of options on
the table as discussions proceed
i have to go back to the comment by the
chairman of the community board
who said there's presently a liability
that can be turned into an asset
and i think as a starting point you
can't get much better than that
okay so is there any other comment on
in terms of
the recommendation i'm very aware that
um
since the council's council since the
community was formed
that council has been incredibly
need to be
um
would be a good way to
so just are there any other items
yeah well i disagree
we have a community board in matera
there's made a recommendation
to its council that it thinks that it
needs to pull
the walls down the swingle and fill it
up
with concrete ask the question then ask
the question
that the building be made order tight
and secured is that not um
what's the next planet
does it
[Music]
made secured water tight a concrete
floor
so then we can proceed with all the rest
of the vision of the of the building
i want to see this happen as much as we
do i guess it's just how do we
get to that point of where
and it's good to see the variety of ages
mainly younger people a few 40 year olds
but it's getting a lot of use and
accessing the old
building is just the obvious next step
i guess counselors so tell me if i'm
wrong
counsellors need to have a clear
understanding of what that looks like
where our part in that process is
certainly that i go back to the half
million dollars so it's probably a
little bit more
million dollars that's been committed
there already by council
that needs to be the basis for
funding applications to bring the rest
of the
money out rather than simply
uh accessing funding from breakfast we
need to
piggyback on the investments we've
already made
but we need to do it
for me was not saying that who should
pay it was around the sea funding but
seeking a little of work together on
this your board is making a
recommendation
and your report for the council to
undertake expenditure
i have no idea what that is so working
together
whether through the working party or
joint uh workshop
is the way forward
[Music]
um
would a joint working party between the
council
or a joint meeting between the council
and the community would be a good
next step
comfortable with that now yeah more than
happy and i'll say
that we would be working together on it
and
we're not coming to council to ask for
money to do this
we're looking at what it costs to do it
and like i said when we got these two
estimates
they were just so weird that one is
quite difficult another estimate and the
big challenge
and that's what we wanted to investigate
i know that there would be people that
would use it
well that's that's our view
[Music]
to make it usable and then
[Music]
so comfortable uh
where the council has sit on this one um
just i'd be interested to see what sort
of dollars we're actually looking at
to get a dollar value around um
what actually have you done because
clearly with the border indicating that
there is a
community interest or a requirement or
have it
an asset there that
or
obviously previous stuff from five years
ago i have no idea of the
costs i think
the meeting between the community board
and council would be the first good step
and i think that meeting should be on
site
so we can all know and understand
the council is comfortable with that
just going back to item three
the community board association
chose south from
comprised
just to have a look at some of the
challenges and the
so with one
alteration um with regard to the way
forward
the next step
between the council which means
first appropriate juncture
somebody like to move the two
rectifications
that we need to
terms of reference that has been drafted
by the chief executive
and a memo here from chief executive and
we have
a suggestion of two councillors plus
two years to be appointed
i speak to this just
just to say worship that this was a an
idea that was spawned
late last year uh in response to
some of the uh project in debt
management challenges that we had and
the question is posed around
are we sitting on assets that could be
realised to
retire some of that debt and
i've nominated councillors guardian and
macdonald or suggested they've been
closed
based on um high levels of enthusiasm
exhibitors last december um
and to balance it out i suggested
perhaps two urban councils but look this
is
your subcommittee you can as a creature
of your design
so you can fill up with how many members
you may wish to have
and in terms of the decision-making
process
i thought it best that you might want to
have just paris to recommend only before
you wake up when
you're sold
[Laughter]
but again that is purely the council's
choice but it's just really a platform
for debate your worship
and um feel free to design these you you
require
it's tempting to go further than there's
the recommender just as just the evening
just to play with that
okay counselors um it's open for
discussion
um i
i hasten to add that we have been down
this track before
we've looked at um various
pockets of land that the council owns
but i think it's appropriate that we do
it again
uh it has been some time since we went
through that process
so we just need to just check and see if
the properties that we own are still
appropriate for the council to own both
as a potentially long-term asset for
right discussion around the supplement
makeup of the subcommittee council
guideline council maternal you're
comfortable with the name
in terms of
so we've um four councillors that have
put their
hands up is there anybody else that's
desperately involved in this particular
adventure it's not i'd probably like to
have my hand in the south
should be included when they're
reviewing properties and or
the assets should they be reviewing what
what they are
being used for presents leases and rents
and that sort of
as part of their scope
yet that would form part of the
consideration
rather than say well if it's least
that's good
and don't don't take the inquiry any
further
i thought it would be yes at least but
how competitive is that lease and is it
better
and higher use for land that may
actually not involved counsel owning it
but whether you want to have that in
trying to change the reference i can
certainly do that if
that's the council's wish
all right what should we need to do on
that one do we need to put
um just in terms of staff representation
on that
committee may be useful to have the ceos
up front
right so
[Music]
right um would somebody like to move
that the
terms of reference um be adopted with
the
changes that we've made in terms of
additions of members
and the appointment
thanks
[Music]
a couple of margins um central
government
was very generous in most terms
with stimulus funding largely water this
was unplanned and
quite budgeted this this money of course
as you might
for a lot of projects particularly the
wooden street
type renewal and also the cctv
investigations
the other
for jobs and this has been a great
initiative which is
attraction community so the majority of
our 78
um on our expenditure side um we're
tracking
overall we're tracking to to budget what
we had intended to
spin there's a few ups and downs between
various cost centers or budget units but
there's there's no more members as
the rating manager has already
highlighted we are experiencing
some shortfalls and budget around solid
waste
opportunities
thank you okay so the reports open
for discussion and or question anybody
have any comments
discussion it's not i'll put the motion
all those in favor please say aye
aye aye against emotions you've done
well
no questions um
so i think that brings us to the end of
the
open